tenemos que simplificar 7 x + 10 al
cuadrado ahora uno puede estar muy
tentado a decir que eso es igual a 7 x
al cuadrado más 10 al cuadrado pero eso
está muy mal es una equivocación que uno
suele hacer al principio pero está muy
mal ok
aquí tenemos un paréntesis y estamos
elevando al cuadrado a todo el
paréntesis y elevar al cuadrado
significa que tenemos que multiplicar a
todo el objeto que estamos elevando al
cuadrado que en este caso es 7 x + 10
todo este paréntesis lo tenemos que
multiplicar por si mismo otra vez
ok tenemos a 7 x + 10 y elevarlo al
cuadrado es lo mismo que volverlo a
multiplicar por otro 7 x
10 es cierto que en algunos casos por
ejemplo cuando tenemos 7x por 10 y
queremos elevar esto al cuadrado nótese
que aquí estamos sumando y aquí estamos
multiplicando y entonces estas dos cosas
no son la misma cosa pero bueno en este
caso esto si es igual a 7x al cuadrado
por 10 al cuadrado ok pero eso es porque
estamos multiplicando entonces al elevar
al cuadrado lo que tenemos es 7x por 10
por 7 x por 10
y podemos cambiar estos términos del
lugar y entonces llegamos a esta
expresión de aquí pero cuando tenemos
este símbolo de más las cosas se
comportan de otra forma pero bueno
déjame borro todo esto pero bueno vamos
a desarrollar esta expresión esta
multiplicación entre dos binomios y para
eso vamos a utilizar dos veces la
propiedad distributiva
ok tomemos este paréntesis entero
y los vamos a multiplicar por siete
equis y a eso le vamos a sumar este
paréntesis por diez y eso es simplemente
aplicar la propiedad distributiva y
entonces lo que nos queda es el
paréntesis
7 x + 10 x 7 x x 7 x + 10 10 por nuestro
paréntesis que es 7 x + 10 y ahora vamos
a volver a utilizar la propiedad
distributiva en cada uno de estos
paréntesis tenemos que multiplicar 7 x
por cada uno de los elementos del
paréntesis y también tenemos que
multiplicar a este 10 por cada uno de
los elementos que se están sumando de
este paréntesis y entonces nos queda 7 x
x 7 x eso es 49 x cuadrado
7 x x 10 eso es 70 x y por aquí nos
queda 10 x 7 x eso es 70 x y finalmente
10 x 10
estos son 100 ahora algo muy interesante
aquí es que en esta expresión si tenemos
a los términos 7x al cuadrado que está
por aquí que es 49 x cuadrada y al
término 10 al cuadrado porque 10 al
cuadrado es 100 pero también estamos
sumando estas dos cosas de aquí en medio
pero podemos ver que cada una de estas
dos cosas es lo que obtenemos si
multiplicamos este término con este
término que 7x por 10 nos da 70 x y
tenemos dos de estos términos por la
forma en la que distribuimos estos
paréntesis
este 70 x proviene de multiplicar este
10 por este 7x que a final de cuentas es
este 10 por este 7x y este 70 x proviene
de multiplicar este 7x por este 10 que
al fin y al cabo proviene de multiplicar
este 10 por este 7x pero bueno al fin y
al cabo lo que nos queda es 49 x
cuadrada más 70 x 70 x o sea 2 x 70 x
que es 140 x más
bien ahora si necesitas hacer estas
cuentas muy rápido y recuerda que todo
esto viene de la propiedad distributiva
pero bueno para hacerlo muy rápido
recuerda que es el primer término
elevado al cuadrado que está por aquí
más la multiplicación de los dos
términos multiplicado por 12 que está
por acá y finalmente el último término
que es el otro término elevado al
cuadrado que es este de aquí